hey what's up guys my name is china
welcome back to part two of this ghost
of sushima
review so far i've been really enjoying
the aesthetic of the game part one is up
there check it out if you haven't
already and without further ado
let's dive in and take a look at jin the
samurai
hi this is nate fox from sucker punch
now we just showed you some exploration
but let's switch gears
and check out some combat
okay i am really excited to see the
gameplay because so far it has been
pretty much just walking around the
environment which is great and it's
lovely but
i do want to see the interaction between
characters and especially the combat
mechanics
because i think that that's something
that's very difficult for games to do
well
and in an engaging way and i've heard
good things about this game so i'm
excited
look at all those white flowers swaying
in the wind
really nice and i have already said this
but i am a fan of the ui for sure
nice little kind of volumetric looking
fog here
little cloud wisps lightning if you've
ever seen a samurai movie you know what
to expect
two warriors sizing each other up
wait i don't think i have seen a samurai
movie before
can you guys suggest something in the
comments below to make the first
move
whoa
let's take a look a little bit more
closely okay these blood effects
are definitely cool if not a little bit
unrealistic
look at that this is that that looks
like some kind of fluid simulation to be
honest
it could be a baked fluid simulation and
thus basically like an animation
but it it doesn't really matter at this
point because it looks great and
obviously it interacts really well with
the environment as well
um it definitely looks kind of 3d so
they could be using some kind of 3d
particle system or fluid simulation as i
mentioned
they slow down the whole uh like game
time every time he slashes a sword which
i'm not sure if that happens for every
single
like attack move because if it would
then i think that'd be a little bit
annoying but it looks really cool
in this video at least the lighting on
the particles is really cool and you can
also see that it's
somewhat three-dimensional lighting it
doesn't look like it's just a flat quad
or anything like that
um which you know i mean thus far a lot
of the particles that we have been
looking at have been
two-dimensional or at least they have
they've looked two-dimensional
but this is really cool i'm not exactly
sure where the light is supposed to be
coming from but
that looks really cool maybe it's
reflecting off of that in which case
that would be even
even better really cool
lots of blood around here oh he's still
he's still going he's still bleeding
yeah that was really cool
there's like in terms of damage models
you know i mean
it's mostly just blood but it gets the
job done i guess and
the way that they've done the blood is
really cool as you can see the mongols
are
everywhere on this island for gin to
succeed
he has to on a side note i've really
been enjoying playing the mongols and
age of empires too just wanted to
use real skill say that decision because
i heard mongols no wasted energy
in fighting them no wasted energy every
strike
must count oh bow and arrow action
that was nice
oh a little deflection there that's cool
reminds me of star wars
parry enemies at the last possible
moment to open them up pretty standard
i wonder if they've done any kind of
like
procedural animation i don't know if
procedural animation's even the right
term for that
but essentially uh artificial
intelligence style driven animation
meaning that like
the animations of the characters respond
to the actions the players are actually
doing dynamically
oh a hand on the floor oh okay so this
is a little bit more
of that damage model i was interested in
there we go so yeah so basically what
i'm saying is that i'm interested to see
if
you know if i swing my sword this way if
the animations how well the animations
may match up together so does my enemy
kind of defend against that and does it
make sense when the two kind of
pieces of weaponry collide because that
that's obviously
a bit of like a next step next-gen style
uh
animation and like combat and by next
gen i don't necessarily mean like future
stuff i just mean like
nowadays i feel like that should be
fairly standard
so that that's what i'm that's what when
i'm looking at this that's what i'm kind
of looking at
i'm looking at how natural does this
look how much does this look like a
movie
essentially yeah see that was really
cool as well it looked like when i
hit him me being the player
you can see that over here actually his
sword
actually hit the it looks like my sword
hit his sword
which is what i was talking about so if
we go back a bit there's the sword being
swung and see he's blocking
he's got his sword here it doesn't even
look like he's blocking maybe just
holding it like that you know
and then the swords actually collide
i don't know if there's any sparks from
that or any kind of impact effect
that would be cool not necessarily
physically accurate but still cool
look at that shock wave as well yeah
this
i quite like this so far
and see that kind of like his sword
actually moved back like
along with the kind of i guess vector
and like um the actual kind of direction
of the hit as well which was really cool
watching that a little bit more there's
that arrow
is gonna deflect it yep
what did he do to him
this looks like a slash i love this
sword bouncing out though
that's really cool the katana
people are going to hate me the sword
that so far a few of these death
animations do look almost identical to
me
but i really like the way that the the
actual
combat mechanics of this and the way
that the animations between
two completely separate characters line
up together
feels really natural that's really
difficult to do well
so in that sense huge props to them
gin the ghost
look at that moonlight reflection that's
really nice as well
over that wet environment they've done a
good job with the dirt at night
it looks pretty good as well these like
you know these wet areas are always
like pretty easy to do a little trick
that artists like to use to make scenes
feel like the graphics are just a lot
better is just to make the scene wet
because as soon as you make the scene
where whether it be like a road or a
field or a building or like whatever
material if it's wet
it's reflective if it's reflective it
looks cool so that's
um in a lot of cases it's very difficult
to make a dry scene like a boring scene
kind of look
look real because it's just it's harder
you know but if you've got water and
reflections everywhere then it just it
just automatically looks good and that's
definitely the case here it looks really
nice
because of that water if it was if it
was like this the whole way what you're
seeing here right now
you'd probably be like uh yeah it looks
looks okay you know
the water's really important but now
let's see him take on the same group of
mongols
as the dishonorable ghost as the ghost
will use every dirty trick you can think
up to is interesting
even using fear as a weapon
which reminds me a little bit of like
far cry 3 just the
gameplay i guess when you have to like
capture those
i don't know it's been so long since i
played it capture those like bases or
whatever the outposts
yeah this really reminds me of far cry 3
i loved that game
yeah that was really cool everything
made contact super well
good animations definitely definitely
good animations great animations
the whole screen shook when he got that
hit
yeah really really nice night
environment though really nice
i love all the subtle particles and like
embers and all that stuff getting
getting up there in the air
oh wow firecracker yep
this also reminds me of [ __ ] 3.
yeah super nice i wonder if his hand
went to where he
went where he like was hit because if so
that's that's really cool
assassinate slaughter i don't know what
the difference is
if there is any
did he not notice that
whoa oh hello hello
hello smoke bomb
let's watch that smoke bomb again look
at that
wow look at that shot look at that depth
of field
we've got some in focus kind of sparks
here in the foreground
really really beautiful artifacts
elements here
that's a really beautiful shot honestly
they did a really good job on this
this is really well balanced and exposed
as well
super nice
takes a little bit of time to come back
and focus as well so they've got that
yep they're varying the amount of
i guess blur the amount of whatever
you'd call that i guess the aperture
maybe
i'm not sure if it's actually physically
based and thus like an aperture which
controls like
essentially what the blur amount is or
if it's actually just like a blur value
because it could just be like a standard
blur with like the blur size
it obviously could just be the focus
shifting as well
they will learn to fear the ghost they
will learn
to fear the ghost i wonder if there's
some kind of deep you know neural
network
kind of layer to this whole ai
because i definitely wouldn't be
surprised if there is based on some of
these animations and
a lot of the other stuff i've seen here
i'm not sure if it because
it's the thing is it's to an extent it's
possible i was going to say easy it's
not that it's
it's not that it's necessarily easy but
it is somewhat possible to fake that
so like instead of actually using a
neural net to like learn that and then
respond to that dynamically you could
just cover all of your bases you know
cover all of your possibilities with
predefined actions and then just you
know if you do enough of them
it seems responsive but it's not
see this environment has a little bit
less going on in it and so immediately
it looks a bit worse
this right here definitely looks almost
a gen
it's almost like there's a generational
leap you know between
this and then what we saw earlier
because this to me looks like it could
be
from any game in the last 10 years
really because there's not much going on
you know this is completely hidden from
any kind of
direct light i mean yeah there's shadows
and there's a lot of
you know potentially baked shadows going
on in the background as well but there's
nothing
interesting here if you look in the if
you look at the
scene that we had before you know like
look at this for example
hopefully this is a good frame you know
there's all this there's all these
flames going on there's a lot more
foreground elements there's trees in the
background that look absolutely amazing
there's some fog there's some smoke
effects there's lights there's warmth
there's
coolness there's this great kind of
juxtaposition between
the cold and the warm elements in the
scene which create a really nice color
balance
that doesn't really exist in these shots
here come on there we go in these shots
here
so yeah it's like it's definitely
interesting how a scene can look
completely different
just without all those little subtle
things in it
this is already looking more interesting
oh some grappling hooks
[Music]
ropes
[Music]
purchased
i did not even see him i mean i was
looking at the cart yeah he was there
the whole time i missed
that shadow was interesting
i just felt like it appeared there
didn't it
what's going on with that leg look at
that leg i guess i went through the
ground
i was wondering what was going on there
look at that leg it looks like it's it's
going through the ground
i thought something was a little after
hold to ignite oh this is are we going
to see a nice explosion
are they going to let us enjoy it
whoa okay
so far i'm a little bit disappointed
because i feel like they didn't let us
enjoy it
maybe you have to actually play the game
to enjoy it cool so lit everything up
no shadows from it it's okay though
to be honest that would be quite amazing
if there were
yeah it's not bad
wow okay lots of fire destroy shipyard
yeah this does remind me of far cry 3 a
lot that's cool though that's a good
thing
all right customizing gin excited to get
into that in the next video hope you
guys enjoyed this combat let me know
what you thought of the combat is this
really
next generation combat i mean i know
this isn't really a next-gen game but
are they using
techniques here that are the future with
more powerful hardware in the next
generation it is going to be
much more possible to spend a lot more
processing power
figuring out animations procedurally and
on the fly as opposed to just baking
you know a bunch of animations possibly
blending between them which is currently
what people
tend to do i should say developers tend
to do based off of these trailers it's
also really
hard to actually analyze things like
that i feel and i think the reason for
that is because
it's a trailer they could have just
literally shown every single possible
animation and thus we don't know
if they're going to repeat certain
animations or how often they pop
up until you actually get your hands on
the game a few people were actually
suggesting that maybe i should pick up
some of these games and actually play
them
and then comment on them based on that
instead of just watching videos
possibly something i will consider in
the future definitely leave a comment
below if that if you feel like that
would be something you would want to
watch but otherwise getting into this
customization stuff next time i think
will be
really cool hopefully i'm going to get
around to doing this next video
this week for sure i was gonna make like
the this part like two days after the
last part but then
i just got bogged down with a whole
bunch of work but hopefully we'll wrap
this up in the coming days thank you
guys for watching i'll see you all next
time goodbye
[Music]
you